[Music]  it's time for et social study your quick  look at what the stars are posting  online everyone has a butt re old winter  took to Instagram to flaunt her booty  while vacationing with friends in Bora  Bora Selena Gomez is slowly making her  way back to social media after a brief  hiatus the 24 year old singer teased  fans with her Instagram videos on  Saturday while having dinner with  Wizards of Waverly Place co-star David  Henry Jessica Simpson shared a snap  while enjoying a meal out with the fam  her daughter Maxwell adorably taught her  son ace how not to get his long blonde  locks in his hot chocolate while  attempting to drink it  [Music]  music legend David Bowie would have been  70 on Sunday and in honor of his  birthday his music video for the song no  plan was released and his wife Iman  took to Instagram to post a beautiful  throwback of the pair together on a  beach in happier times  [Music]